even before the official paris motor
show got underway volkswagen was here to
present its new models to the press and
the new passat gte was the star of the
evening
just like its best-selling cousin the
golf gte is a plug-in hybrid drive this
time in the mid-size class
in e-mode the passat gte has a range of
up to 50 kilometers after that the
combustion engine takes over with a full
tank and battery the range is about 1
000 kilometers that would take you from
paris to london and back again
volkswagen's martin vintacorn says the
passat gte is another step in the
direction of meeting europe's goal to
reduce passenger car emissions to 95
grams of co2 per kilometer by 2020
hybrid cars can help make that happen so
vw is investing in the technology
bmw slogan at the paris motor show this
year is let the sun shine in and one of
the sunniest ways to do that is with the
new 2-series convertible
bmw's how about diese calls it the
sportiest and most dynamic convertible
in its class
it's grown a bit and features more
comfort and a very powerful engine with
over 300 horsepower the m235i is the
first performance model in this segment
prices for the 2 series convertible
start at close to 36 000 euros for the 2
liter gas powered model with 184
horsepower
the open top 4 seeder will go on sale
just in time for the 2015 season
the soft top roof is electrically
powered so it opens and closes in just
20 seconds
opel is celebrating four world premieres
at the paris motor show the mocap
safirip and insignia have benefited from
revamped powertrains
then there's also the slick and spirited
new atom s and as a real highlight the
new corsa
is always a hit the first corsa debuted
here 32 years ago this is the course of
5.
audi also has a debut at the paris motor
show the new tt roadster it features a
folding cloth roof aluminum to keep
weight in check slightly reduced length
and up to 310 horsepower
like its hard top brother it sports a
sharper revamped design there's also the
signature single frame grille and
trapezoidal headlights
the modular construction also helps
limit the weight which boosts
responsiveness
all-wheel drive is standard on the
powerful sportback version which sprints
from zero to 100 in less than five
seconds
audi's early hackenberg says the paris
show is one of europe's premier car
events paris takes place on even years
in frankfurt on odd numbered ones so
it's where audi can show europe and the
world what it's got in the works
musically accompanied by one republic
mercedes is presenting the next
generation of its b-class
available with every kind of engine
including fully electric and natural gas
a new fender and a wider twin slat grill
round out the facelift
mercedes ceo did session says the b
class has been super successful in its
three years on the market
they're aiming to set the pace again
the redesigned front end features led
headlights plus there's an upgraded
interior with bigger monitors
there's a natural gas version and a
fully electric version
that makes the b-class the most
versatile car in its segment
porsche is using paris to unveil its
fourth generation cayenne first on stage
is the cayenne s e hybrid the first
plug-in hybrid in the premium suv
segment
it's a frugal giant officially using
only 3.4 liters of fuel per 100
kilometers that's 79 grams of co2 per
kilometer
porsche's martial says the problem with
alternative engines is that they still
cost more than conventional ones
the customer has to decide whether to
shell out for a more sustainable and
eco-friendly car
in paris toyota confirmed its status as
one of the most innovative manufacturers
worldwide presenting some fascinating
concept cars
the world's number one car maker plans
to best the competition with a
mass-produced hydrogen engine
the yet to be named fuel cell vehicle
will be available first in japan and
from next summer in europe as well
another world premiere in paris is the
seahad leon experience
with permanent all-wheel drive and
special experience badging the youngest
member of the seyad family offers
driving enjoyment that doesn't stop when
the road ends
this all-terrain wagon rides higher than
the leon st with a higher clearance to
match
the design features robust protective
covering on the side sills and wheel
wells eye catchers include the gutsy
front end with big air intakes and
integrated fog lights with turn signal
function and the front spoiler with
aluminum trim
and skoda is looking to paris to bust
out of its image of sensible and
somewhat frumpy cars
care for a t-shirt here you can create
your own design and take it home
the czech brand is also presenting its
completely revamped fabia compact in
various versions
the fabia is skoda's first model series
to display the design's evolution toward
more expression and emotion with accents
from motor racing
it's a showcase of crystalline forms
sharp lines and precision in every
detail
and the party over at mazda is
celebrating the 25th birthday of its
iconic mx-5 roadster where as
generations 2 and 3 stayed close to the
mx-5's original design the latest
version is completely reworked with a
noticeably more modern look
the hood conceals the newest high
compression gasoline engines of the sky
active series with either a six-speed
manual or coming soon automatic
transmission
and nissan is taking the vw golf head on
with its pulser series in paris it
unveiled a completely redeveloped series
featuring an extra roomy interior see
the future of driving at the paris auto
show through october 19th
peugeot has given its 508 a facelift the
mid-range model is available as a sedan
crossover or station wagon the station
wagon is the main body variant and
around 80 percent of buyers choose it
powered by an 88 kilowatt gasoline
engine the base model sells for just
over 26 000 euros in germany
swedish carmaker volvo will launch
production of the xc90 in early 2015.
the second generation suv will be built
at volvo's toslanda factory near
gothenburg
it offers a wide range of features and
typical for volvo plenty of safety
equipment
only one engine option is known so far
the drive e diesel produces 165
kilowatts and consumes just under 8
liters of fuel per 100 kilometers
sasha is taking a look at the jeep
renegade renegade can mean someone who
deserts one country for another and that
could apply to this jeep which sports an
all-american design but was built in
italy but before we start thinking about
spaghetti westerns let's see what the
renegade can do especially off-road
the new compact jeep is available with
many extras and engine variants that's
unusual for a jeep it also means it's no
longer necessary to import the cars from
the us
besides the sport longitude and limited
variants it's also available as a top of
the line trail hawk
that's the one we're driving it is also
the most expensive and cost 31 900 euros
in germany
sasha realizes quickly this italian is
the equal of its american stable mates
in every way that's a good
sign jeeps first got their start back in
the 1940s with the willys mb
the us army built it as a small
all-terrain vehicle
that history is still visible here since
1941 is embossed on the dash in large
letters and jeep hopes some of that
tradition will rub off on this italian
model we'll have to see if it works but
there are other allusions to the
original 1941g
the renegade has visual cues to the
early jeep in many places beginning with
the trademark grille with its seven slot
vertical grille
the tiny x within the d on the renegade
badge is a nod to the spare jerry that
jeeps once carried this x can also be
seen in the tail lights and you can even
see hints of the iconic front end in the
rear lights
the trunk's maximum capacity is just
under 1300 liters
in 1941 the interior of the jeep was
very simple today that's fortunately not
the case but it's still not what you'd
call luxurious
the jeep is available in two gasoline
and two diesel engines
performance ranges from 81 to 125
kilowatts
sasha says five driving modes assist the
driver off-road here in the auto mode
crossing the terrain was still a snap
which means there's still plenty of
latitude for harder terrain
the renegade is available with front and
all-wheel drive the select terrain
assistance system has settings for snow
sand mud and rocks
the rock setting is only available in
the trail hawk and activates the rear
differential lock thus enabling a low
creep speed and greater control in
demanding terrain
the first jeep had no problem with water
but we don't recommend trying that today
but even so the off-road capability is
remarkable its suspension can travel
20.5 centimeters so it can master even
the biggest bumps
and on the road the renegade cuts a good
figure in our test drive thanks to its
firm suspension but it's a lot more
exciting away from the pavement
sasha says testing off-road cars is
always a perk of the job and the cheap
renegade is no exception but it's also
well-mannered on-road we'll have to wait
and see what the fiat counterpart the
500x will bring
the fiat is likely to be a bit cheaper
and perhaps almost as good
a jeep made in italy may be a switch but
sasha's always been a fan of italian
movies too
meet the bmw 503 cabriolet a car that
wowed car lovers it was the first german
car with an electric soft top as
standard equipment
its chassis was entirely of aluminum it
was the first mass-produced car with a
light alloy v8 engine and the sound was
music to the ear
in 1956 bmw brought out the company's
most expensive model up to then the 503
in the coupe and convertible versions
each sold for 29 500 marks the price of
a single family home
mikiel pritchard has owned this 503
cabriolet for 16 years now and he's
still thrilled by it
he invites us to imagine it's 1956 just
11 years after the end of world war ii
suddenly there's the first car with a v8
engine and 140 horsepower and it can go
190 kilometers an hour
that stacked up to the mercedes 300 sl
with its gold wing doors which was a
gigantic car
there really wasn't much else like it in
germany at the time for him the 503
still tops it all
in
as a weekly any shower in uber
the 503 cabriolet was a luxury car for
factory owners and film stars
wealthy industrialists like count faber
costell and rudolph auguste erdkat drove
them in the 1950s
the elegant two-door model took home
gold medals from car shows in khan rome
lisbon and vienna
absolutely michelle
waxes enthusiastic about the car's power
comfort and size
the technology is simple nicer than in
modern cars
the 503 holds four people comfortably
making it great for holidays and that's
without sacrificing sportiness the only
thing to slow him down is when there's
traffic on the road
is the [ __ ]
the aluminum chassis was built by the
chassis specialist company bauer and
stuttgart the design didn't follow any
trends from abroad bmw came up with it
on its own
the 503 marked a turning point in bmw
design a shift from pre-war taste to a
leaner and more modern look
the understated pontoon shape did
without flashy effects and followed the
ideal proportions of a gran turismo car
a long hood and a short rear end
in its technology the 503 was based on
the big bmw sedans the 501 and 502 the
frame engine transmission and axles were
almost identical for its fans the 503
still ranks as the most beautiful car of
its day
always loved the 503's design it's an
absolute eye-catcher the coupe is
already a looker and the convertible is
stunning
it's still the pinnacle of what bmw has
to offer
the interior is impressive too with its
clean beauty and 1950s aesthetics
three round gauges inlaid in a metal
dashboard and a few ivory colored
buttons in 1956 this was the
state-of-the-art luxury
but the 503 came at a difficult time for
bmw
few people in post-war germany could
afford such exclusive cars bmw produced
only 139 of the convertible version over
the course of five years
by the late 1950s bmw was on the verge
of bankruptcy the company rescued itself
with small cars like the iseta and the
bmw 700 but of course they didn't have
the luxury or the power of a 503
the engine the world's first cast
aluminum v8 was a masterpiece of german
engineering
two carburetors fed it fuel
later versions had output of 119
kilowatts at the time even mercedes was
offering only six cylinder engines
michiel picho loves taking his
convertible for a spin here in the
bavarian alps these days the vintage
beauty is clearly an exclusive ride but
on the road it draws admiring rather
than envious glances
it's a familiar scenario he's out on the
road and another car passes him the
driver and passengers glance over and
their jaws drop there's a flurry of
pointing and other cars slow out
and the passengers all start snapping
pictures on their cameras and cell
phones
it's all good fun
today a 503 convertible in good shape
will set you back a quarter of a million
euros when it comes to vintage cars
bmw's 503 is a crown jewel
you